the movie begins with the introduction
of Jordan Turner an operator working at
the 911 emergency headquarters in Los
Angeles she receives hundreds of calls
during her shift some of which are very
serious however Jordan has always
managed to keep calm and guide the
stressed people out of danger this has
made her a well-respected and popular
figure in the department they should
probably all be good at their jobs but
what can you do it's 2023 one day Jordan
receives a call from a young woman named
Leia who faintly Whispers that an
intruder is trying to break into her
house hearing this Jordan immediately
tracks her cell phone's location and
sends some cops to help her she then
instructs Leia to hide and lock herself
in a room the terrified girl obliges and
she slowly makes her way upstairs as the
Intruder enters the house he begins to
search the rooms right then he notices a
window slightly open and Leia's shoes on
the ground beneath it this makes him
assume that she must have escaped the
house already he then proceeds to go
downstairs and pursue her not realizing
that Leia is actually under the the bed
what kind of idiot takes their shoes off
to jump out a window suddenly the 9-1-1
call from Leia's phone abruptly ends
causing Jordan to panic and redial the
number unfortunately the ringtone alerts
the Intruder of Leia's hiding location
and he eventually drags her out he then
takes her phone and starts talking to
Jordan the latter desperately asks him
to surrender saying the cops are on
their way but the Intruder is unfazed in
a scary voice he tells her it's too late
before hanging up the call the incident
leaves Jordan in a State of Shock and
she starts blaming herself for the poor
girl's death a few days later Jordan
returns to work but she is still
traumatized and nervous to begin her
duty to make matters worse the news
reveals that Leia's corpse was found in
a very horrible condition near the
highway Jordan cannot take it anymore so
she stops her work and goes to the
balcony for some fresh air her boyfriend
Paul who happens to be a cough at the
same Department joins her for her
support he tries explaining that these
things are common in today's world
nobody puts their phone on silent people
are idiots honey but Jordan is too
depressed to listen to him the movie
then fast forwards by six months Jordan
is still struggling from anxiety so she
has now quit her job as an operator
instead she works as a trainer for new
recruits as this job doesn't require
interaction with the emergency callers
she is performing well somewhere else
two teenage girls Autumn and Casey are
hanging out at a mall it is a fine
morning and they are waiting for their
other friends to arrive but just then
Autumn gets a call from her boyfriend
and rushes to meet him in a hurry she
leaves her phone behind so Casey keeps
it with her later she returns home and
while walking through the parking lot a
car suddenly reverses nearly hitting her
Casey curses at the driver and picks up
her now broken phone to her bad luck the
driver becomes enraged and attacks her
from behind he then knocks her
unconscious using chloroform puts her
inside his car trunk and drives away at
the 911 headquarters as Jordan is
instructing the new recruits an operator
suddenly receives a call it turns out to
be from Casey who has just regained
Consciousness inside the car's trunk
since her phone was damaged earlier
she's using Autumn's phone right now the
operator tries asking her questions but
Casey is so panicked that she can't even
form a sentence properly hence with no
options left Jordan takes over the call
she is the most experienced operator in
the building she tries tracing Casey's
location but unfortunately her phone is
a simple one which doesn't use GPS
Jordan then goes for Plan B and asks the
teenager if she remembers anything while
getting kidnapped Casey who is about to
have a heart attack digs deep and
eventually remembers that she is inside
a red car and that the kidnapper is
wearing glasses however the information
is not enough so Jordan asks Casey to
break the tail light and Survey the
surroundings the latter successfully
does is asked and when she waves her
hand through the hole a woman spots her
and calls 9-1-1 with this Jordan finally
learns the car's license plate number
but when she runs it she learns that the
kidnapper is using a fake identity
moreover when the woman goes against
Jordan's suggestion and drives him
kidnapper to get a better look at his
appearance he becomes suspicious and
abruptly exits the highway as they're
back to square one now Jordan tells
Casey to search the trunk for any useful
items the terrified girl looks around
and finds a can of paint a screwdriver
and a shovel as soon as she sees the
shovel Casey panicked and she thinks
that the kidnapper intends to kill her
and bury her with it however Jordan
manages to calm her down she then
instructs Casey to pour the paint
outside so that the cops can easily spot
it from a helicopter unfortunately when
the kidnapper stops at a red light a
random driver unaware of the situation
approaches him and reveals about the
leaking white paint this alarms the
kidnapper so he immediately jumps the
red light and drives to a secluded area
he then opens the trunk and threatens
Casey unaware that she has a phone on
her that's right he's too dumb to check
her Pockets meanwhile the driver from
earlier has become suspicious at the
abrupt departure of the man so he
follows him and parks nearby assuming
that he is trying to hide something in
the trunk the driver tries to front the
kidnapper but while doing so he gets
attacked and knocked down with the
shovel the kidnapper then changes cars
loads both of them and drives off in the
following scene Paul and his partner
follow the paint Trail and discover the
kidnapper's abandoned car Paul also
notices Blood on the side of the car and
a smashed bottle of chloroform this
gives him an idea he can now use the
bottle to get the kidnapper's
fingerprint meanwhile Casey continues
talking to Jordan describing the new
vehicle they're in suddenly the driver
next to her wakes up and starts
screaming this alerts the kidnapper so
he Parks the car eliminates the driver
and then puts his corpse back in the
trunk at this point Casey has become
certain that she is not going to make it
out alive she starts saying her final
prayers but Jordan once again calms her
down and asks her to retrieve the ID of
the driver Casey obliges and using the
information on the card Jordan finally
gets to know about the car they are in
the kidnapper has no idea what pockets
are right then the kidnapper realizes
that he is running low on gas so he
pulls over at gas station Casey whose
phone battery is also low uses this
opportunity to climb through the back
seat of the car and scream for help the
plan works and a nearby worker notices
her but before he can even react the
kidnapper eliminates him by spraying gas
and setting him on fire he then knocks
Casey unconscious and closes the trunk
this is the sloppiest crime since OJ
because of the incident Jordan loses
contact with Casey and becomes worried
but thankfully using the fingerprint
from the broken glass bottle the police
identify the kidnapper as Michael Foster
Paul as soon as they get the information
Paul and his subordinates rushed to
Michael's house to gather leads and
question his wife meanwhile Michael
arrives at his destination and picks up
Casey from the car trunk to his dismay
when he checks the girl he discovers a
phone that is still connected to the
police when he picks it up Jordan
addresses him by his full name and
informs him that the cops are at his
home interrogating his family she also
warns him to surrender and leave Casey
but Michael replied is that it's too
late as soon as Jordan hears these words
she realizes that Michael is the same
person who kidnapped and murdered Leia
six months ago this twist means
absolutely nothing elsewhere as Paul is
scanning through the kidnapper's house
he comes across a picture it features a
woman who looks eerily similar to Leia
she is revealed to be Michael's deceased
sister Paul immediately asks Michael's
wife about the location of the picture
and the latter identifies it as Santa
Clarita Hills wasting no time the cops
head there but once again they don't
find anything in the meantime Michael
brings Casey to an underground bunker
and starts preparing her for a medical
procedure he binds her to the chair
however she manages to wrench her arms
free and spray him with insecticide
Casey then attempts to flee but sadly
Michael easily kidnaps her at this point
it has become midnight but Jordan is
still at the call center trying to find
another clue in the case later Paul
contacts her and promises that Casey
will be found alive and that the police
are searching every passing vehicle in
the vicinity despite this Jordan is not
satisfied so she decides to take matters
into her own hands she heads to
Michael's abandoned old house where she
discovers some pictures of his family as
Jordan goes through them she finally
gets to know that Michael's sister died
of cancer and that Casey is also of the
same age assuming that it is too late a
dejected Jordan prepares to leave but
just then she hears the same background
noise that she had heard earlier in
Casey's phone call recording Jordan then
looks around and discovers Casey's
smashed phone and an underground hatch
this is when it finally Dawns on her
that Michael carries out all of his
heinous crimes inside the bunker Jordan
wants to call for backup but she also is
scared that it may alarm the kidnapper
hence after much deliberation she heads
inside the bunker herself as soon as
Jordan reaches the base she discovers
Michael getting ready for something she
then hides in a corner while Michael
starts stroking a blonde wig that
resembles his sister's hair seeing Blood
on the ground Jordan realizes that the
hair and Michael's hand has been
recently pulled from one of his victims
scalps it is then revealed that the
kidnapper misses his late sister so much
that he kidnaps girls resembling her
appearance and scalps them he then
stores them in a mini fridge as a
souvenir in the next scene when Michael
prepares to cut through Casey's scalp
Jordan comes out of her hiding place and
hits him with a mannequin head knocking
him unconscious she then manages to free
Casey from the surgical table and
proceeds to flee the place however to
their battle lock Michael gets up and
attacks Jordan just as he is about to
finish her off Casey strikes him in the
head causing him to stumble and fall to
the ground the two girls then get out of
the bunker with Michael following them
slowly as soon as he reaches the top
they attack him and mercilessly throw
him to the bottom of the bunker feeling
safe for the first time Jordan plans to
call for backup but Casey stops her
revealing that she has another plan
let's scalp this in the final
scene when Michael wakes up he finds
himself chained to the same surgical
seat Jordan and Casey then approach him
and mention that they will leave him in
the bunker as a punishment for his
crimes hearing this Michael panics and
starts crying he begs to call the cops
and get him arrested but the girls
completely ignore him and leave the room
the movie ends with a satisfying note as
The Psychotic killer is left to rot
inside the bunker because the police
definitely won't ask any questions about
where they found him or anything like
that
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching